les forces ukrainiennes avancent avec
prudence malgré la retraite rue
sannonçait par Moscou mercredi l'armée
de Kiev se garde bien de clamer-victoire
dans cette bataille
depuis longtemps et depuis deux semaines
nous savions qu'il renforçait leur
position sans être prêt à tenir la rive
droite
rien ne nous assurer mais nous savons
que nous devrons encore nous battre
les troupes russes sont ordres de
franchir le Nièvre pour se regrouper sur
la rive est hors de cette ville
stratégique proche de la Crimée toujours
discret lorsqu'il s'agit de donner des
détails concrets des batailles le
président ukrainien ne révèle rien de
l'opération militaire en cours
il y a eu beaucoup de joie aujourd'hui
et nous comprenons clairement pourquoi
mais nos émotions doivent toujours être
contenues en période de guerre
je ne donnerai pas l'ennemi tous les
détails de nos opérations que ce soit
dans le sud à l'est à l'ouest nulle part
quand nous obtiendrons des résultats
tout le monde le verra
une méfiance partagée dans les rues de
Kiev
ironnement
russes jouent à quelque chose on ne
devrait pas leur faire confiance
ce n'est pas pour rien qu'ils ont
rassemblé 40000 soldats là-bas je pense
qu'il prépare quelque chose contre
l'armée ukrainienne les autorités
redoutent une difficile bataille urbaine
qui piègerait leurs troupes les
Ukrainiens connaissent le prix du sang
selon l'armée américaine cent mille
dollars soldats ont été tués ou blessés
depuis neuf mois selon ces mêmes
estimations les troupes russes auraient
subis les mêmes pertes